REMOVING FANG FANG'S BOYFRIEND
FROM THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
WE BEGIN WITH A SPECIAL LOOK AT
THE BIDEN CENTER FOR DIPLOMACY
AND ENGAGEMENT MADE POSSIBLE IT
APPEARS BY THE COMMUNIST PARTY
OF CHINA.
IN 2014 SHORTLY AFTER
ESTABLISHING THE ACADEMIC
CENTER, ALL IN BIDEN'S NAME
AND APPOINTING THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT NATIONAL SECURITY
CONCERNS AND NOW LOW AND BEHOLD
BREAKING THIS WEEK, A TROVE OF
TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
INCLUDING SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTED INFORMATION FROM
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WERE UNCOVERED IN A PRIVATE
UNSECURED OFFICE AT THE BIDEN
CENTER FOR DIPLOMACY AND
ENGAGEMENT IN A FOLDER THAT WAS
MARKED VP PERSONAL.
NOW, THIS REPORTEDLY INCLUDES
SECRET MATERIAL SURROUNDING THE
U.K., IRAN, UKRAINE.
TO PUT IT SIMPLY, THANKS TO JOE
BIDEN, AMERICA'S MOST SENSITIVE
SECRETS WERE FLOATING AROUND IN
AN UNSECURED OFFICE THAT WAS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY THE CCP.
NOW, PERHAPS SOMETHING NEFARIOUS
AS A PLAY OR MAYBE IT'S JOE
BIDEN, JUST LIKE SANDY BERGER.
SLOPPY.
JUST BEING SLOPPY.
DO YOU REMEMBER SANDY BERGER?
HE TOOK DOCUMENTS.
HE SHOVED THEM DOWN HIS PANTS,
SOCKS.
EVERYBODY SAID, HE'S JUST
SLOPPY.
HE DIDN'T DO IT ON PURPOSE.
IT ACCIDENTALLY FELL INTO HIS
PANTS.
EITHER WAY, ACCORDING TO THE
MEDIA MOB AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THIS IS A SERIOUS
OFFENSE.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT BIDEN SAID
ONLY FOUR SHORT MONTHS AGO WHEN
HE WAS ON "60 MINUTES" ONE OF
THOSE RARE INTERVIEWS THAT HE
GAVE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN YOU SAW THE PHOTOGRAPH
OF THE TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS LAID
OUT ON THE FLOOR AT MAR A-LAGO,
WHAT DID YOU THINK TO YOURSELF,
LOOKING AT THAT IMAGE?
>> HOW THAT COULD POSSIBLY
HAPPEN.
HOW ANYONE COULD BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE.
AND I THOUGHT WHAT DATA WAS IN
THERE THAT MAY COMPROMISE
SOURCES AND METHODS?
BY THAT I MEAN NAMES OF PEOPLE
WHO HELPED, ETC?
AND JUST TOTALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Sean: HOW COULD ANYONE BE
THAT IRRESPONSIBLE?
ALL RIGHT.
TONIGHT MAYBE BIDEN SHOULD BE
ASKING HIMSELF THAT QUESTION.
NOW, OF COURSE, JOE BIDEN
DOESN'T NEED TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
WHY SHOULD HE?
HE'S GOT DON LEMON, LIBERAL
MORNING JOE, LADIES OF "THE
VIEW."
HE'S GOT TWO FAKE NEWS NETWORKS,
FAKE NEWS CNN, WASHINGTON POST,
NEW YORK TIMES.
THREE NETWORKS, ABC, CBS, NBC
AND DOZENS OF OTHER OUTLETS THAT
ARE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DEFEND
THE PRESIDENT AGAINST ALL ODDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
REVIEWING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
FOUND IN A PERSONAL OFFICE FOR
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
THIS DISCOVERY APPEARS TO BE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
HAPPENED AT MAR A-LAGO.
WE'LL EXPLAIN.
>> THIS WILL BE POLITICIZED.
I IMAGINE IT HAS ALREADY BEEN
POLITICIZED BY THOSE ON THE
RIGHT AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> WE ALL KNOW TRUMP IS A LIAR
AND A THIEF.
WE KNOW THAT.
SO IT'S NOT THAT BIG A JUMP TO
SAY THAT HE OBSTRUCTED AND HE
LIED.
WE DON'T THINK BIDEN IS A LIAR
AND A THIEF SO WE GIVE HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
>> THERE'S NO COMPARISON HERE.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE KIDS WOULD
CALL FALSE EQUIVALENCY.
>> Sean: FOR TWO LONG YEARS
THERE WAS NO OVERSIGHT AT ALL OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
NOT FROM THE DEMOCRATIC HOUSE
AND SENATE.
NOT FROM THE POLITICIZED DOJ.
CERTAINLY NOT FROM THE MEDIA
MOB.
BUT THAT IS ALL ABOUT TO CHANGE.
BY THE WAY, NOT A MOMENT TOO
SOON.
UNDER BIDEN, THE IRS HAS BEEN
TARGETING, GET THIS, THEY'VE
BEEN TARGETING NOT THE RICH, AS
THEY ALWAYS CLAIM, BUT WORKING
AND MIDDLE CLASS AMERICANS AT A
FAR GREATER RATE THAN WEALTHY
AMERICANS.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS WILL
GET EVEN WORSE IF BIDEN GETS HIS
WAY AND MORE THAN DOUBLES THE
SIGH OF THE IRS WITH 87,000 NEW
AGENTS.
MORE THAN DOUBLE.
OF COURSE, THE IRS WILL, OF
COURSE, NEED ALL THE HELP IT CAN
GET TO SQUEEZE AMERICANS TO PAY
FOR BIDEN'S OUT OF CONTROL
SPENDING, BUT NOW NOT ONLY IS
BIDEN COMING FOR YOUR PAY CHECK,
BUT HE'S ALSO COMING FOR YOUR
STOVE.
YOU HEARD ME RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS NOW
ATTEMPTING TO BAN ALL GAS OVENS
AND BURNERS.
THAT'S LIKE HALF THE COUNTRY.
MAYBE WE'LL GET JOE BIDEN'S
STOVES DELIVERED TO OUR HOUSE
FOR FREE.
ANYWAY, PREDICATED BY THE GREEN
NEW DEAL, THESE RADICAL
EXTREMISTS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, THEY WANT TO CONTROL THE
WAY YOU NOW COOK.
I THOUGHT MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WAS
BAD WHEN HE TOOK AWAY MY BIG
GULP.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL THE WAY YOU
EAT, THE WAY YOU TRAVEL, THE WAY
YOU POWER YOUR HOME, YOUR CAR.
WHAT ABOUT YOUR CHAIN SAW, YOUR
LAWN MOWER?
GOD FORBID IF YOU EVER USE A
LEAF BLOWER.
THEY WANT TO CONTROL EVERY
ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE, WOMB TO
TOMB.
SEEMINGLY, THE ONLY THING THEY
DON'T WANT TO CONTROL IS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
NOW, BIDEN IS EVEN TAKING DOWN
BARRIERS IN ARIZONA, ALL WHILE
BUILDING HIS OWN WALL AROUND HIS
BEACH HOUSE.
HE THINKS WALLS WORK IN
DELAWARE.
THE PRESIDENT MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND TONIGHT THERE'S ONE GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE NOW READY TO PUT
IN